اكد رئيس الوزراء الماليزي انور ابراهيم
ان لجنه العمل الخاصه بتتبع الاموال
المنهوبه في قضيه الصندوق الماليزي لا
تزال تعمل لاستعاده اكبر قدر ممكن من تلك
الاموال البالغه نحو 35 مليار دولار وفي
لقاء خاص مع برنامج المقابله الذي يقدمه
زميل علي الضفيري وصف ابراهيم الصراع بين
الولايات المتحده والصين بالامر المؤسف
الذي يسبب لبلده الكثير من المشاكل لا
سيما انه بلد تجاري يعتمد على بيجين
ومنخرط في الوقت عينه بعلاقات وديه للغايه
مع واشنطن
نلفت عنايه مشاهدينا الى ان الجزء الاول
من اللقاء الخاص مع رئيس الوزراء الماليزي
انور ابراهيم ياتيكم ضمن برنامج المقابله
للزميل علي الضفيري الذي يبث مساء الاحد
في العاشره مساء بتوقيت مكه المكرمه